[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
je m'apprête à partir
et là c'est réel c'est concret parce
qu'une fois que je serai là dedans je
fais tout seul en totale autonomie sans
gps sans tracker sans balises sans
téléphone satellite
aucun moyen de contacter le reste du
monde donc il y aura que moi et le vide
ça fait quelque chose agca pour cet
après midi jusqu'à ce que je pose mon
camp ce soir et après un deuxième groupe
pour cuisiner ce soir et pour la soirée
là c'est horrible parce que j'ai
vraiment très très chaud y'a aucun
espace dhombres j'ai soif et je peux pas
boire plus que que mes réserves
tu peux pas tous boire là d'un coup j'ai
obligé de me restreindre la jce watch
c'est vraiment dur
par la fatigue et l'énervement un peu de
la journée parce que c'était dur j'ai
quand même super content d'être là j'ai
aucun regret c'est un lieu incroyable et
ça fait partie des choses que je vais
pas vivre tous les jours dans ma vie
donc il faut que je profite de cet
instant ici je vois rien autour de moi
[Applaudissements]
je crois que je viens de là bas mais je
suis pas totalement sûr je te le garder
ce cap touquet
[Musique]
j'ai vérifié mon cap tous les 100 mètres
et tous les 100 mètres je me rends
compte qu'en fait j'étais en train de
dévier et que je dois changer de
direction du quick a marché avec la
boussole dans la main ça c'est compliqué
[Musique]
ces extrêmes sais pas comment j'ai fait
pour faire une petite halte cuisson là
dedans mais j'ai réussi ça brûle on a
tort
par contre ces extrêmes ce soir ça va
être vraiment une nuit etc
attentats les accroché à ma de
poche à eau et à mon sac de l'autre côté
et voilà
[Musique]
voilà donc le désert se trouve ici et je
ne suis plus dedans je suis enfin sorti
du salar de uyuni j'ai rejoint la terre
les cailloux ça sort sur autre chose que
sur du sel parce que j'en avais marre
d'avoir les fesses toutes blanches à
cause de ça donc voilà c'est la fin de
cette aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude donc des airs de 30 kg de
départ de copier une moyenne de 23
kilomètres parcourus ce désert
[Musique]